يعني انا اعتقد ان
الايران استفادت من تجارب الماضي
السياسه التي اعتمدت في الماضي
سواء يعني في المنطقه العربيه او مع
العالم
مع كثير من دول العالم
ادركت بانها سياسه
مضره وغير منتجه وغير مفيده
والقاعده تقول والصلح خير
وطبعا هذا التلاقي بين يعني الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران وبين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
اذا تم ان شاء الله سيكون له اصداء
ايجابيه واثار ايجابيه في المنطقه كلها
وفي العلاقات بين عموم المسلمين
فيما بينهم يعني ولذلك ما يسمى بمبدا
التقيه يعني التقيه في السياسه موجوده في
العالم ككل يعني ليست خصوصيه
ايرانيه
موجوده من يمكن ان يقترح شيئا وان يخالفه
ولكن دائما الحكم يكون يعني على الاعمال
وهو من خلال
ترجمتها للاقوال
ونحن يعني
نتفاءل خيرا بان هناك تغييرا في السياسات
التي
احدثت مثل هذه الفرقه بين المسلمين في هذه
المنطقه وفي غيرها